Okay Michael, are you ready?
>> I am afraid so.
>> All right, which one do you want to fill out first?
>> Let's just do them in order, so ,one nearest neighbor. You, you explained,
how the training works. We just take the assorted list, and leave it there.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And we have the classifier, or the aggressor itself ,has linear space,
and now at query time, we need to find the nearest neighbor, Um-huh.
>> Which we could do by taking the query
point, and running through the whole list ,and seeing which
one it's closest to, but, because, it's sorted I think
we, we outta be able to use binary search and,
and in log time, find the closest, point to the query.
>> That's exactly right, you should be able to do
that in log base, two time. What if it weren't sorted?
>> Yeah then, like I said, I think you could just scan through the whole
list and that would be linear time and that's not a big deal.
>> Right, yeah, we could do linear time, but, because I gave you a
sorted list, because, I'm so helpful, you
can do it in [INAUDIBLE] time, okay, but.
>> That was, that was very, very thoughtful of you.
>> It was I thought, I thought of her, so what about on the, space side?
>> Alright, so the amount of space that you need to process its query is
linear. We don't need to take any special,
set aside, space beyond, a couple simple variables.
And the data that we're given, which we've already accounted for.
>> Right, so then why would it be linear, if we accounted for it?
>> Did I say linear? I meant constant.
>> Yes, yes, that's right,
constant. That's what you meant. That's what you said. That's what happened.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Okay.
>> It's a good thing, this wasn't being recorded,
so we could verify one way or the other.
>> [LAUGH] It is a good thing, maybe we'll
look it up on Wikipedia, and it'll say confusingly [LAUGH]
>> Linear sometimes use to mean constant.
>> Constant. [LAUGH]. Yeah, that is pretty confusing.
>> Okay, what about k and n?
>> Alright, K and n. So k and n, so the training process,
the learning process, is exactly the same, as it is for one year stamper,
which is to say you do nothing and you pass all the data
forward, to the, The query processor. So it's going to be 1 n.
>> That is correct, nice.
>> Now querying, seems like its a little more subtle. So
we can find the single nearest neighbor in log and time.
>> Mm-mm.
>> Where we going to get the other K minus one? So, I'm pretty sure,
that ,once we find the nearest neighbor we can kind of start doing a little,
Spread out search, from there, until we found the k nearest neighbors.
>> Sure. So, you're saying, you know,
you've got these points. They're already in a
line, you find the nearest neighbor. You
know ,the, the next nearest neighbors have to
be within k of the points surrounding it, and so you can just move in
kind of, either direction and pick them up as you go. Yeah, something like that.
>> Okay.
>> I mean the way that, the way that I
was thinking about it is that, I, I think you
can use the same algorithm that you used for merging lists, in merge sort,
but here the lists actually corresponds, to being, to the left of the query
point, and being to the right of the query point and they are both
sorted ,in terms of their distance from the query point. Sure, yeah, I buy that.
>> So, so that ought to give us log n, plus k.
>> Okay, so, do we need to write the k?
>> I'm going to say yes, because, if k is
on the order of like, n over 2, then it's going to dominate. If k is on
the order of log n, then it's not
going to dominate. Mm, that's a good point. So,
yeah, we'll do k. I will point out that if k is on the order of
n over 2, you're right, it will dominate, and then really this is big o of n.
>> That's right.
>> But if it's on the order of log n, then it's
just log n plus n, and so it's a big old long
n, log n. But ,you're right, so we should probably keep the
k around because, we don't know its relationship to n. Okay, fair enough.
Okay, what about the space requirements?
>> We know one bit of relationship, it's smaller than or equal to n.
>> That's true.
>> Because that would be really weird, if I gave you
ten data points and asked you for the 20 nearest neighbors.
>> That's the sort of thing you would do.
>> It's the sort of thing you would
do, but then ,it would be really confusing.
>> No, no, no, it's the sort of
thing YOU would do, again, let's go to Wikipedia.
>> Confusingly, twenty sometimes means ten. [LAUGH]
>> Okay. So what about space?
>> Space, so, I don't understand why,
it would ever need more than constant space.
So, so we're going to, zip around in that. I mean, I guess, if
do it really badly ,we can use K space. To kind of copy over
what those, possible nearest neighbors are. But ,we don't need to keep track
of them. We can just point to them in place, so it's constant.
>> Okay,
yea that's true in fact, because, it's sorted all you really need
to know is the beginning and the ending. So, that's two things
that's constant. Okay, cool, alright, good,
so what about linear regression? Your
favorite little algorithm thing that you did? When we talked about this before.
>> I do like, linear regression. The learning in
this case, is what we are mapping, real number
input to a real number output. The way we
are doing that is we are taking, its probably
M X plus B sort of form [CROSSTALK]. We
need to find, the multiplier and the additive constant. which,
It seems, like, in general doing a regression involves,
inverting a matrix. But, in this case,I think the matrix
that we're talking about is of constant size. So
inverting, is, constant time. I think, it's as easy ,as
basically just scanning through the list ,to populate that,
that ,constant size matrix. So, I'm going to say order n.
>> Yep.
>> To process the data.
>> That is correct.
>> There's probably a really nice algorithm for that.
>> Yeah, probably some kind of linear regression algorithm.
>> Yeah. [LAUGH] No, I mean like the general
linear regression algorithm is, is involves inverting a matrix.
>> Right.
>> Or something like it, something equivalent to it. But here
because, we're, it's all in scaler land, I think it's simpler.
>> Yeah, I think that's right. Okay ,so what about space?
>> All right, so space interpreted
the data that you passed forward from
the learning algorithm, to the regressor, is just,
well MX plus B. It's just M and B, which is constant. There's the two numbers.
>> Right, that's 2, 2 is like 1,
[UNKNOWN] large values [LAUGH] of 1, so it's constant.
>> Yeah, All right, now at query time, you give me an X.
I multiply, it by M and add B, so that's constant time [CROSSTALK]. So,
before the query, cost was expensive and the learning
cost was cheap. And now we've kind of swapped that around.
>> Yeah, we have, so space would be.
>> Space, oh, that you're asking me?
>> Yeah.
>> Space for the query would be constant as well.
>> Right, exactly, so yeah, so you made
a good point here. So earlier on, we had
the situation where learning was fast, was constant, and
querying was, you know, not as fast. It was,
you know, probably logarithmic. But, in the regression case,
learning was expensive and the querying was easy, so
we swapped around, that's exactly right. So, why would
you care about that, well, let's see, I'll point
out something, which is though, even though we swapped
out what was expensive in terms of time and
what wasn't, you'll notice that. It's only logarithmic at
query time for these first two but it's linear for
the learning time, in, linear regression, so doesn't that
mean that linear regression is always slower and worse?
>> No really, because we only have to
learn once, but we can query many, many times.
>> Right, right. So I guess if we query more than, you know,
n times for example ,it'll certainly be,
worse overall. In terms of running time.
>> That's right.
>> Okay.
>> Though, it's, though it's interesting, because like when I see numbers
like this, my, my algorithm, hat tells me that
I should try to balance them a little bit more.
Like, here it's, it's you can make, learning ,essentially
free and the other one you can make querying essentially
free. Really you want to split those, somewhat evenly. Though
it's, not obvious to me how you would do that.
Like, square root of n, learning time and then
square root of n query time or something like that.
>> Yeah, but you did say something else that was
important right? Which is that you only have to learn once.
>> Yeah, It's true.
>> So, the balance you know, really depends
on how often you're going to do querying and
exactly, what power it gives you. I mean,
the trade off is really there. Don't you think?
>> Yeah, I guess so. I mean so, so specifically,
in the, in the version where you just query ones.
>> Right.
>> Then the balance thing could be more interesting.
>> Sure, okay, cool. All right anything else
you want to observe about this. Let's see,
we got the trade off between learning versus
querying. So, either you do all your work upfront,
or, you put it ,off ,and do your work only, when you're forced to at query time.
>> Yeah, I guess, well one thing, is, I want to point out that there's
a nice Mr. Rodgers, reference in the title. That was, that was very cool.
>> Thank you very much. And the second thing, is
that it does strike me, in a sense, that what's going
on here for the nearest neighbor algorithms, is that you
just put off ,doing any work until you absolutely have to.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Which strikes me as kind of a procrastinatory approach.
>> So that's a good word, that you used there, procrastinate.
The words that people use, in the literature, are ,uh, lazy.
>> Mm.
>> They say that these are lazy learners, versus
something like linear regression, which is an eager learner.
>> Eager.
>> Yes. So, linear regression, is eager, it wants to learn right away, and it
does, but nearest neighbor algorithms are lazy. They
want to put off, learning until they absolutely ,have
to, and so we refer to this class ,as lazy and this class as eager.
>> I See, so I guess its the case, that, if
we never query it, then the lazy learner definitely comes out ahead.
>> Right, that makes sense.
>> Yeah.
>> It's just in time learning, or JIL. [LAUGH]
Or JITL, I guess, which doesn't roll off the tongue
anywhere near as well. Okay, cool. So we've gotten
through this quiz. Would you like to do another one?
>> Yeah, I just have to get this JITL off my tongue.
>> [LAUGH]